hast du irgendein endboss beschwert oder
was macht also atemgeräusche weil ich
meine lieben freunde herzlich willkommen
zurück bei minecraft hero und ich
brauche wolle
ihr könnt den ball haben oder strings
hast du strings ich habe keine chance du
darfst nicht abschließend ich denke dass
da es ein ein string auch aber vier
können wir hier sonst welche seien
allgemeine das ist von den hilfe immer
mit jetzt hier erst knapp dahinter her
schon du brauchst wolle ja so viel input
ort wo ist keine zwei wolle das aber
steht ganz viele strings welche da frage
ich doch gerade ich hab auch keine
strings
die habe ich schon so weitergemacht r2
wolle hätte ich ehrlich mir glaube ich
schon oder zumindest strings dafür tritt
man wolle ja ich dachte brauchst du
wollte zum bauen oder so war es ist das
für ein komischer kilo mann wird erst
nicht aus voller schön wäre es astro fun
regatta bisschen mit jetzt auf dem
ostring findest immer danke voll nett
von dir
danach werden wir ein abenteuer erleben
bist du gerade auf dem weißen ding
er war das denn hätte ich nicht also
zwei drinks habe ich
ja du brauchst aber viel mehr braucht
man vier strings oder baumann 842 wolle
er kommen einfach zu mir passt welche
dieser friedhof 2000
das ist nicht ob sondern irgendeinen so
generierter gib mal
ich glaube das ist dein eigener friedhof
von apple in meiner stadt
da sitzt ein spiegel jetzt stimmt
solchen ausprobieren aber nein du
brauchst ein blog über dir so gut
klappen thema kommen
ich öffne es jetzt für ihn raus es
wurden raus marco russland ich bin zu
hause
aber egal schicksals macinga david du
bist doch dieser lucanet der der bringt
einfach alles bei sein ganzes wissen ja
das ist ja nicht so viel macht gerade
musik mit querflöte echt ja ich höre
nichts kommt von mir und bringen wir
wollen mit ich dachte du wolltest du mir
corp sollte dir ja ich kann auch zu dir
ja du musst aber alles fertig haben da
fast jeder nach direkt aufbringen können
und ein abenteuer starten kann von hier
aus
ja gut weiter dann packe ich eben die
sache rein hast du hast du denn wolle
für mich oder strings slips hier lassen
mal gucken basic collins tina gaedt
strings michael j mit 44 ja beste leben
man braucht du hast zwei bringt zwei
matt ich geb dir sechs moment habe ich
spiegel habe ich goldene feder mein
agent sport repariere ich noch mal eben
ganz kurz ich habe beides kranichfeld
traurig kürzlich reparieren weil ich
kein level haben
ich kann es nicht reparieren vielleicht
hast du zu wenig länger so das kann
schon sein und feiern ja ganz viele
schoko pro vätern in stadt roth regnet
ist gerade das ist doof als ich kann
ihnen fast nichts draufpacken sagst du
einfach mal in meinen ja wenn es kaputt
ist ist ja auch egal eigentlich wenn das
das ändert wort kaffee besser ein stör
auch schon wartet dann nehme ich das
noch eben mit so ändert so etwas auch
schon halb kaputt ist und jetzt
teleportieren ich mich im stadtrat
gemacht
louis
30 schüler kommt zu dir kommen oder ok
hey komm gib mir bis hier oben
sie verstehen so zwei wolle habe ich und
jetzt machen wir gleich gut sind dann
laufen wir los
ich mache ein bisschen dürfen solange
disco pogo war falsch rum porto ich das
schon irgendwie mein axel bäck kaputt es
geht nicht es geht nicht weit fertig
gleich die verzaubern irgendwie musste
sogar also ans kinn so schnell kaputt
kannst du das eben machen weil ich habe
gar keine lange ich habe auch gar keiner
will mehr und meine sind auch nicht
verzaubert sich gerade
ich guck mal fertig ist kostenlos es ist
ein loch hätte gehen schon so kaputt
wenn man ja eben so dass nicht zu viel
benutzten
ich würde sagen wir nutzen bevorzugt
sterbe oder nicht
ich geh mal kurz zurück oder sterbe
nutzen
ich gehe mal ganz kurz zurück in meine
stadt wieder warum weil ich da moment
vielleicht habe ich da noch was
das blau ich bin gespannt
einfach von mir das von dir aus
loslaufen ist eben die pfuhler bei dir
sage euch besser weil das noch nicht so
viele vorspiel bei uns wird er alle
haben wir uns alles fahrer vorstellig
lassen wir versuchen zum statt geld zu
kommen da war ich ja gar nicht gut ist
kannst du komplett verzaubern ohne
probleme gehen da ist werde ich ihnen
machen also macht auf jeden fall
anbrechen halt drauf kommt aber ich kann
nicht so heftig lasst einfach so
entdecken so bisschen er ich kann nicht
so viel kämpfen jetzt mit der rüstung
ich beschütze dich für kleine sohn luca
ich bin für dich da
da kommt jetzt alles drauf was geht du
hast es heftig wie viel das buch das
trimega viel drauf alter wie viele
verzauberungen wie das aussieht wenn da
alles drauf ist ja sein krass da kommen
die schühchen rein da drauf und da das
eigentlich fertig solltet ihr kommt dann
ein spiegel
da droht wo könnte denn statt geld sein
statt gelb rot statt gelb wenn ich
wollte noch zu dir kommen oder nicht
stop schorn nein wir wollten aber wir
wollten ich bin mir ziemlich sicher dass
ich zu dir kommen wollte dass unsere
stadt
das heißt da oben ist irgendwo statt
geld sein
wir müssen in diese richtung laufen
damit ihr zustand geld kommt den erlass
von dir einfach loslaufen züchtet gelb
oder von mir von dir
ok familie co star ich hunger man muss
so etwas essen
das hat auch gut mit den spielern kann
man jetzt immer hin und her
teleportieren wenn wir dann irgendwann
sind da nicht reinfallen okay vom bistum
bei mir der ich mal ein portal machen
sollen aber habe ich bisher noch nicht
was noch nicht ist kann ja noch werden
hoffmann ich bin so ein game ohne ich
habe eine skala moore halb an dann fit
wie ein viertel will bot an das kk du
bist halt ein paradiesvogel mensch wert
ist auch halb kaputt sogar mehr als halb
so man das tue ich find's schön wenn
zauberstab der leuchtet auch gar nicht
so richtig wenn der fall so deshalb
verzaubert aber wartet noch ein
stuff mit wir können ja theoretisch auch
eigentlich wenn wir dann irgendwo
unterwegs sind kann ich dann mit vince
darf die zombie mit zauberstäben die die
ganzen monster dann irgendwie bomben
weshalb ja genau ich einfach dass das
team bin bei ich bin bei gesichts felsen
und handy soll ich kurz gucken wohin
laufen damit in richtung statt gelb
laufen ja warum ist das da oben alles
schon so gut dass herzliches danke unten
das ist ja dass eure stadt das da ist
unsere stadt
dementsprechend müsste da ca
lokal rechnen hat mich überkommt richtig
ja da müsste statt geld sei nirgendwo
ich habe mark als gesetzt wie draußen
wir müssen kam jetzt mit müssen hier hin
den er in die richtung so gut dass über
nacht loslaufen aber egal
yalla rechnet mit dem real estate
verlaufen wie es wirbelwind ja so lange
wie geht die mit dem kannst über wasser
laufen
aja dallas erst mal fliegen casting
thema parat
boah wert ist lacroix und können aber
2013 reden sich ja fast vorbei war ja
stimmt wie war denn das ja für dich das
ist gut so ist er umgezogen ist schon
heftig ja das stimmt schon ich hab ja
lasst doch lieber mit normalen schon
laufen weil das starke voll kaputt also
mit denen schon mit den schnellen schon
okay of two auf jeden fall ja das java
voll krass war ich bin halt erstmal mehr
ausreicht den wir kuscheln oder stupsen
einfach geradeaus laufen haben wir dabei
leider wenig anlass zu machen weil man
steht immer irgendwann unter auch weil
es ein bug ist oder so okay ein
schnäppchen machen aus einem axt ich
habe david beckham - mal gebraucht ich
mag machst du schon grad ich mache das
bildchen macht ganz viele boote okay
weil die je nach kaputten seite habe
jetzt fünf reicht das
ja ich hatte diese mengen details hakt
es kommt einfach alles zurück so meine
angst ich geb dir einfach mal drei ab
was das publikum immer wieder zurück was
mir dass meine axt ist welche axt im
magnetisierung sex ich hab gar keine
magnetisierung suckt gerade fällt mir
ein herr diese kommt es dann trotzdem
zurück irgendwie irgendwas total zauber
von der rüstung vielleicht weil das
deine schuhe fahrzeuge auf magnet
das wöchentlich das auch bei mir grad
nicht warte ich mach das so
erst aus so also das jetzt war weiterhin
ich bin viel zu schnell mit den schuhen
okay wenn man nicht in die richtung nein
nicht sofort boot
okay nicht sofort blut ja erst mal
laufen aber man geht irgendwann unter
erstmal so ok gut ich bin hinter dir ja
pläne oder gleich schnell
ich glaube dass schneller fühlt sich
schneller an was ist wenn ich jetzt ein
zauberstab lorenz darf oder so kann
seine tour noch schneller bist wo es
geschafft bis ans ende
dabei wird nicht schneller dadurch man
wird nur denken man wird nur was man
kann den gegner damit wegdrücken guckt
mich an wo bist du okay lauf einfach
lauf einfach weg ich freue mich für
einen ding und weißbier gefunden dafür
zwischen eisbär kuscheln nicht mehr
es war da ab angst vor tieren wenn die
unter wasser sind dem strategieschwenk
weil plötzlich angefangen zu brennen ich
dachte es wird so ein dem dämon oder so
hat sich geradezu buback entwickelt bei
steinmeiers mit der antike sich zu
kolorieren jetzt erst mal keine türme
wir versuchen jetzt erstmal zu statt
geld zu kommen
nach mehr als bei yahoo ich habe auch
sogar schon mal ein rennen
die eisbahn ein mammut alle giraffe wo
es hat gedauert
das finde ich lustig kommst du mit denen
auf doping
ich meine jeder irgendwie seine
gruppierung von leuten die er hasst du
hast du hast werde ich ab bern
dann will wir das gibts doch komme hat
sand firma aber comcom klar mit den ja
ehrlich kommt er gut klar mit denen ich
komm nicht so gut klar mit den bären
erst kohl mit denen ja die bären diesen
kacke bisschen wir reingehen ebenfalls
ein bisschen paranoia schieben können
wir gar nicht wann ich habe keine
rüstung aus man nennt es das schloss war
da nicht schon mal jemand der
heimatstadt ohne ein spot ganz viel und
ich bin genau darin das machen bitte
aber ich kann dich hab doch fast keine
rüstung aber ich mache das so gerne
coahuila wenig ins kookbooks schon sehen
ich irgendwie drauf pc los machen
ja ich bin auch schon drauf bist du das
es gibt auch viel erfahrung es gibt
alles ja aber die kacke ist wahr ich
guck mal wie viel schaden die wir machen
weil eigentlich dürfte nämlich fast
direkt würden
hast du gard irgendwie nennt post
beschwert oder was macht also komischen
geräusche yahoo.de noch stehen alle
getötet die die hier waren ja aus
sondern so viele nur zwei oder drei
das war aber auch die mitte gehen ok ja
geduldig in der kampf und ich habe ein
bisschen angst in wien
naja ich hab manchmal weckt das bei mir
und habe ich angst vor diesen normalen
walker sind so schlecht holzschwerter
hand ist da und nicht helft ihr schießt
auf die para el pass auf dass du dich
mich trifft meinig schließt sich aus gar
doppelt doppeltes nein habe ich nicht
niemals erfolg geschossen
ich kenne ja auch gerade hardware nils
staab sieht zufolge bringt doch fall
zusammen ist gar nicht im blut ein
er kommt auch hin dann kannst du auch
was nehmen willst aber ich habe echt
also wenn ihr bekommen ich will dir
einfach absolut kein ding ja ich hab
echt angst wieder halbe leben nur das
ist so kacke wenn ich keine rüstung
haben ja ja das kann man die echt so
boxen einfach durchgängig ich helfe euch
einfach von oben dann kannst du dir da
ein bisschen was können okay hier ist
essen
ich hab hunger ich fühle die erfahrung
bisschen aber wir sind besser als in
anderen dann schluss herr durch fenster
ein bisschen sehen bedrohlicher aus
paradis werden nimmt der typ hier wird
geheilt verblödet pizza siehst du das
schon ein riesen unterschied zur
normalen und die machen wir immer so
bedrohliche geräusche der rock holt
registerkarte der woche also wenn in der
inbox finde ich so am allerschlimmsten
von allen was macht ich hatte noch nie
einen gesehen jetzt mega stark alter der
teleportiert sich auch die hinterher und
so hatte ich richtig angst und der sich
jetzt willst du mir der herr
teleportiert bis ich halt raus genossen
den update bist du ich bin fest ich bin
fest dass 16 von 20 durch gar nicht fast
to dabei sie zu doof wenn das so schwarz
ich weiß dass ich das fahrrad schwarz
eine böse farbe wie heißt die versorgung
nicht weitergehen auch hier sind ihr
euch weiter anstatt geld wollen das doch
schaffen
können wir ja nie du kannst es nur
machen oder ich gehe schon mal vor
nein wo ist denn dieser boss ich kämpfe
einfach nur gegen den boss ich weiß gar
nicht ob dann boss ist nicht so nicht
also warum sollte keiner sein und wie
sich hier oben keine hier oben sind nur
so doofe kisten mit nicht mal richtig
guten sachen drin
ich kann nicht wahr sein könnt ihr
einfach können wir einfach den hier sind
walker spaß diesmal ich kann keinen
rucksack im rucksack touren das traurig
wir machen auch immer besser was ich
spaß die preise attraktiv die relativ
gut sind
doch spiegel fackel über wir dachten ja
immerhin diamant schwerte also schlecht
sind sondern packe um mein gott ich habe
ein paar gute sachen sind ja echt nicht
drin
doch schon als ausgerechnet da war nicht
so gutes drin
musik zum beispiel was hast du
verschmäht in welche richtung müssen wir
weiter lockert typ weihnachtsstimmung
juhu ich zeig dir die richtung dahin
siehst du mich
nein
schiedsmann pfeil hoch wo du bist ja da
kann man draußen oder so will mit ihr
zusammen weiter reifen was ist das für
ein dorf davon müssen wir auch das dorf
im wasser auf stelzen kommt trainer wir
müssen jetzt weiter in diese richtung
auf dem urban über wasser laufen
ich mag besser laufen wir müssten
eigentlich gleich sogar schon okay was
als gleiche sind jetzt glaube ich 2000
blöcke gelaufen bisher wie lang die
folge noch eine minute
wenn wir das sind wenn wir jetzt schon
ben jetzt schauen wir haben schon freuen
überzogen ok freunde wenn es euch
gefallen hat dann lasst eine bewertung
dar und an den wir uns beim ich bin
untergegangen und die boote sind in
meinem rucksack und ein wartet das noch
machen dass ich auf dem boot sitzen das
sind 5 und 1
ich hab einen rucksack hingeschmissen
ohnehin es stiftung
das wird das ende vom sogenannten
concorde
ich habe ein rucksack wieder okay meine
lieben freunde wir sehen uns dann
nächste folge wieder